our home star the Sun is just one of 200
billion stars that make up our galaxy
but how did this vast collection of
stars first form
view the Milky Way with imaginary dark
matter goggles and you'll find a clue
a halo of dark matter surrounding the
galaxy a Dark Matter halo
helps the galaxy form simply by
providing gravity to pull things
together catalyzing it and that may have
allowed our galaxy to form the gravity
from this huge construct brought regular
matter in to form the Milky Way in the
middle one of the most amazing
discoveries of the last few decades is
that galaxies form these vast super
structures that actually span the known
universe the great wall is a filament of
galaxies that stretches hundreds of
millions of light years to understand
how these vast galactic structures
formed astronomers use telescopes like
the Atacama Large millimeter
or Alma for short it's an array of 66
radio telescopes and so powerful it can
peer back billions of years to the
formation of the earliest galactic
structures now Alma can actually look
back into the history of the universe
and see similar structures being formed
by these giant baby galaxies sort of a
proto Great Wall
[Music]
Alma gives us a snapshot of how the
adolescent universe evolved
it shows us that as the universe
expanded the newborn galaxies aligned
with their neighbors It was as if the
expanding universe was producing sticky
filaments and the materials building new
galaxies were sticking to these threads
like flies to a spider silk it turns out
these invisible filaments are dark
matter it's like a scaffolding of dark
matter that was pulling normal matter
into it as the universe expanded the
original clumps of dark matter didn't
expand as quickly as the rest they stuck
together like sticky taffy with their
powerful gravity shaping them into
filaments the filaments formed a
sprawling web of dark matter strands
stretching throughout the universe
the gravity of this Dark Matter web then
dragged in normal matter which built up
with the filaments meet and eventually
collapsed to form galaxies the thicker
filaments pulled in the most gas
providing the building blocks for galaxy
clusters
[Music]